so it looks like kevin spoilers is the
last one out with a shongxi breakdown
you can unsubscribe dislike all you want
but don't let the door hit you on the
way back as we have a lot of big
theories for the post-credits scene of
the marvel movie that i haven't seen
discussed in any of the videos they were
great yeah sure they were great i think
there's a lot of big clues as to when
the movie is set in the timeline how it
sets up secret wars and also what it
tells us about the upcoming she-hulk
show we're going to be discussing it all
in this video but heavy spoilers ahead
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out then i highly recommend that you
check out now smash the thumbs up button
if you enjoy the video and don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
each and every day without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
shanghi and the legend of the ten rings
okay so first up i wanna discuss the
second post credits scene as i think
that's the most straightforward of the
two as always if you don't wanna hear
the sound of my voice narrating what
you've just seen in a very dull british
accent then time codes will be linked
below and i won't be mad at you for
skipping ahead i promise
okay so there are they gone yeah what a
bunch of bloody they were i put all this
work into this video and they just skip
ahead oh anyway the the second post
credits scene sees shyling taking up her
father's organization also known as the
ten rings we were told that she was
disbanding the group however we find her
in a similar position to what when we
was sitting on a throne as their
fighters started trying to take over
everything before we talk about this
though i think we need to discuss how
the movie plays out in order to fully
understand how we got to this point now
we start the movie over 1 000 years ago
and see how the ten rings enabled her
father to become immortal and build his
organization over the centuries early on
in the film we take a trip to the past
and learn the full back story of the
real mandarin i said the real mandarin
the real mandarin perfection now tony
luang perfectly plays the antagonist and
he makes for one of the most compelling
villains in the mcu due to his heavily
emotionally enthused portrayal of the
marvel universe's greatest criminal mind
due to the power of the rings when we
build a vast empire known as the ten
rings and in the film we very much see
the power of one's name and how it
builds a legend this idea of family and
the past has a massive influence on the
key characters and it very much sets up
the direction that both chongqi and his
sister will be traveling in turns out
that this idea of a name and the power
that it holds is what inspired uldrich
killian to adopt the moniker the
mandarin and when wu very much brushes
the idea of iron man 3 to the side in
order to cement himself we see that
after when we meets the guardian of a
mystical village called talo can you go
he falls in love with her and decides to
leave the rings behind the pair start a
family but after she's murdered by a
group known as the iron gang he becomes
the man that he once was in order to
exact revenge the guy said get iron gang
and they thought he meant iron man hey
[Music]
earlier on in the movie when we pushed
his son to follow in his footsteps and
he very much brushed shaolin to the side
however she was spurred on by this and
secretly trained herself in the ways of
the ten rings this idea of living up to
what her father wanted her to be i think
very much explains why she took over the
empire and i do believe that she will be
one of the big foes in the next film the
film follows shang chi and xia ling as
they try and stop wen wu from unleashing
a soul-sucking monster who reminds me of
my mother-in-law now this creature has
hypnotized the villain into believing
that it's actually his wife and thus he
sets out to tallow in order to free it
unfortunately he learns the truth too
late and is killed by the monster but
this allows the ten rings to be taken
over by charling who steps into his
place as the new ruler in the final
scene she's joined by jon jon and also
razorfist showing that she's
encompassing her already established
endeavors and pulling them together with
her father's organization now though it
is possible that she's gonna end up
guiding the ten rings on a more positive
path i think that we can tell by the
themes in the film that she's more
inclined to be like her dear old dad the
two parental figures in the movie aka
ying li and wen wu both have an
influence on their children and chongqi
ends up acting a lot more like the
former whereas shia ling becomes a lot
more like the latter it is possible that
in the future we will see shong chi end
up as a guardian of tarlow much like his
mother whereas his sister will do the
complete opposite however if his dad
wanted him to take over he should have
put 10 rings on it hey i'll stop with
all that i think that a couple of phases
will have to happen before we get to
this point but this idea is hinted at
when chongqi ends up unlocking the full
potential of the rings which glow orange
in the same way that they did when his
mother possessed them this is something
that his father could not do and this
idea of being worthy is something that
we've of course seen in the likes of
thor's hammer juxtaposing this shia ling
will take the opposite path and much
like her father she'll end up continuing
to boost the ten rings as a vast
criminal empire now because of where
we're introduced to her i think we can
guess who she'll be working with in the
movie we meet her in macau and learn
that she ran away from her father's
compound in order to create a fighting
tournament there shaolin built a vast
business that pulls in people from
around the world and it could be
possible that this caught the attention
of someone else who was operating in
asia at the time in falcon in the winter
soldier we learned that sharon carter
had ended up building her own criminal
empire in madrapuer and that she was now
going under the identity of the power
broker in order to remanufacture the
super soldier serum though this was
destroyed the series ended with her
getting a foothold in america and she
was given access to all manner of
operations we know that she was speaking
to someone else about joining her plans
and taking over and it is possible that
the pair know one another and that they
will be working together in the future
to infiltrate the us there are also
currently a vast number of black widows
out in the world as well and i have a
feeling that shia ling will end up
reaching out or working with these
groups in order to build an
international empire that has agents in
every country around the world now
interestingly this idea of her mother's
ideology being part of the organization
can also be seen in the symbol itself as
her flower is now in the center
originally there were two blades but
this has been changed up in order to
reflect the new mindset anyway shout out
to ryan airy from screen crush pointing
out that the rings themselves could
actually be a combination of the rings
and the quantum bands in the comics
they're far more like the infinity
stones with each ring possessing its own
power and ability however marvel clearly
didn't just want to simply repeat the
past and they've meshed the two ideas
together in order to form the rings what
do you mean i said i wasn't talking
about while the other videos weren't up
but this has actually been shown in
things like the tesseract which was an
amalgamation of the space stone and also
the cosmic cube from the comics as for
the bands they could be wielded by
someone who was deemed as being worthy
and these cosmic bracelets were worn
around the wrists much like the rings
are they themselves pulled from the
quantum realm and it is possible that
this beacon may have also awakened kang
the conqueror whose home of chronopolis
could be seen in ant-man quantomania i
actually think that scharling will
attempt to get these back from her
brother as they are of course the symbol
of the organization and there's also a
possibility that she is worthy too much
like her brother she has aspects of both
her father and mother and her
personality and these two sides of the
same coin to me are the key to unlocking
the full potential of the ten rings now
in the comics the rings themselves were
actually created by an alien race known
as the mcluhan which fing fang fume
originates from in the prologue it is
said that the rings possibly came from a
crater and this could have been caused
by a meteorite which the great protector
may have traveled along with feng fang
fume is a potential character that the
beacon could have reached out to and it
is possible that he will be coming into
the sequel as we've already been
introduced to a dragon like creature in
this one speaking of the rings that
takes us perfectly into the second post
credit scene which heavily revolves
around their true nature being revealed
as we've talked about they did send out
a beacon and though it could be
messaging the mcluhan i actually have
another theory that i think makes a lot
of sense from what we know about the
future of the mcu now the film ends with
wong arriving at a restaurant and he
takes seong and katie to the sanctum
sanctorum here they encounter bruce
banner and carol danvers through similar
hologram tech to what we saw in endgame
now in endgame carol's hair was quite
short and due to the length we see here
i'd say that it's been at least a year
since the blip brought everyone back
bruce is also back to normal and no
longer professor hulk and i think that
the last avengers movie gave us a big
clue about how this could have happened
in the film we watched as banner figured
out a way to push time through someone
instead of pushing someone through time
and it is possible to use this to
reverse the effects of his
transformation we do know that mark
ruffalo will be appearing in the
upcoming she-hulk series i'm guessing
that if smart hulk was in it that the
cgi budget would be bigger than my ego
though i enjoyed smart hulk i'm someone
who prefers the idea of the jolly green
giant being a curse so i'm glad they
pressed the reset button on it and
returned it to what it was now due to
our rough estimation about the timeline
i would say that this movie takes place
way after the events of no way home in
the trailer for the upcoming spider-man
movie we watched as one went on vacation
and it is possible that he then met with
the abomination and started to train him
like what we see in the movie anyway the
beacon could have reached out to a
number of potential people and i've seen
a lot of youtubers say that they believe
it's galactus personally i don't think
that's the case as he's not connected to
chongqi or the rings and that would be
like introducing darkseid through a
jimmy olsen comic
what do you mean that's exactly what
happened anyway i think that's unlikely
and the three possibilities that i've
settled on are thing fang fume the
celestials and the beyonder now we've
already talked about the first and the
second option will likely be confirmed
in the next couple of months from the
trailer we know that the celestials have
been awakened and in the teaser we see a
celestial egg traveling to earth in the
comics this creates a new celestial and
though they are being portrayed as the
good guys it's possible that stopping
them will also be a requirement for
saving the planet now the last option is
kind of my wild card but yeah just
you've sat this long so hear me out now
the beyonder isn't really that famous of
a character but those who are aware of
the comics will know that he was pivotal
to the secret wars story in that book
the multiverse was torn open and the
beyonder pulled together the fragments
of it in order to form a new earth that
was called battleworld this was divided
up into continents all with their own
rulers and we watched as versions of the
characters from across the multiverse
battled for their own survival we
already know that the multiverse is
going to be a big part of the mcu in the
next phase and it would be awesome to
see characters from the x-men and sony
verse going head-to-head in order to
join the mcu timeline now my theory for
the next film is that we discover that a
beacon has been sent out across the
cosmos and that it's been picked up by
the bionde during this time shirlene
ends up gaining access to the ten rings
and she takes these from her brother the
beyonder then arrives on earth to find
her starting to take over and he takes
her under his wing to formulate the next
part of his plan after tearing the
multiverse apart he forms battleworld
and puts her in charge due to her
knowledge of running a fighting
tournament from here we watches all of
the franchises from pretty much every
single studio get pulled together and
this forms one mcu timeline in which
everything is canon the multiverse also
being split open and the rings being
connected to the quantum realm may call
forth kang who could continue to be the
big bad for the next phase what i love
about the idea of he who remains in kang
is that you never know if you're going
to be seeing a good or evil version of
the character and it just opens the door
for so many possibilities i think it
would be amazing if the secret wars
storyline happened and we met a version
of kang that seemed to be good on the
surface
he could help the heroes pull together
the multiverse into one timeline only
then to reveal that he did this to rule
over the entire thing i absolutely love
that twist i know it's a long shot i
think the pieces are in place that could
hint towards this
now as for my thoughts on the film i
have to say that i really really enjoyed
the first hour though i did have some
issues with the pacing in the second i
feel that everything was incredible
until they hit the village and then from
there it kind of went off the rails a
bit
slowed right down and introduced a
threat that i didn't really think was
all that necessary personally i would
have preferred it if they'd kept the
mandarin as the main body and that's
simply because i found him far more
interesting than the soul-sucking
dwellers that were shoehorned in
that being said the movie is steeped
with a lot of history amazing action
scenes and it also contains one of the
best villains in the mcu i actually
thought that this film would completely
wipe all of iron man 3 out and though it
does to some extent i actually
appreciate that they managed to
incorporate trevor in some way so people
that liked that movie which i'm ashamed
to say i did don't feel like it's been
dumped on this is what an origin story
should be in my opinion and it really
succeeded in its goal of getting me
completely invested in chongqi and the
future of the ten rings though is
intended in terms of complexity i think
the character building here is
absolutely amazing and the action scenes
are some of the best choreographed
moments in the entire mcu chongqi had
the difficult task of not only competing
with other comic book movies but it also
had to go head-to-head with kung fu
blockbusters as well i actually think
that it manages to hold its own against
both in the genre and it excels in terms
of storytelling and action even if the
second hour is worse than the first in
my opinion normally i spoil marvel
movies for myself due to leaks and
speaking to people that have seen it at
premieres but outside of the
post-credits scene i went into this
movie completely blind and i'm so glad
that i did
even with the vaults i had i can't
completely understand why the movie went
the way that it did it's just my
personal preference that we would have
stuck with when we was the major threat
rather than pushing in this hypnotic
dragon but you know they they need to
sell toys and a big action spectacle for
the third act that being said i really
hope that this gets the attention it
deserves and i know there is probably a
lot riding on this in terms of whether
venom the eternals and no way home gets
delayed so yeah if you haven't seen it
for whatever reason then go and watch it
and make up your own mind as i know
there's people out there who hated it
and also some that think it's in the top
five marvel movies ever i'm not sure
exactly where i rank it however i will
be going back to watch it again and now
i have my issues i did have fun overall
there are some minor criticisms here and
there but the good far outweighs the bad
and because of this chongqi gets an 8
out of 10.
now obviously let me know your thoughts
on the film below and as a thank you for
dropping a comment you'll be entered
into a prize through on the 30th of
september in which we're giving away
three copies of zack snyder's dc trilogy
the winners of the last month are on
screen right now and if you want a
chance for this one then just leave a
like drop a comment and make sure you
subscribe to the channel with
notifications on if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the perfect scene
in x-men first class which will be
linked on screen right now i think the
movie is absolutely incredible and i
love talking about the coin scene in it
so definitely go check it out right
after this without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace